اكد وزير الخارجيه الروسيسرجي لابروف
التواصل الى اتفاق مبدئي لانضمام ايران
الى مسار المباحثات الروسيه السوريه
التركيه وقال لابروف في مؤتمر صحفيا في
موسكو مع نظيره المصري سامح شكري ان من
المنطقي مشاركه طهران لانها جزء من ثلاثي
السنه المنخرط في تسويه سوريا
العلاقات مع الرئيس السوري بشكل عام
وبتطبيع العلاقات بين البلدين الجارين
سنكون مستعدين لتطوير العمل المقابل بكل
السبل الممكنه وبطبيعه الحال توصلنا
الاتفاق المبدئي بشان مشاركه ايران في هذا
العمل
روسيا وايران وتركيا جزء من ثلاثيه
تماما مشاركه ايران
قال الرئيس ابراهيم رئيسي ان من سماهم
الاعداء غاضبون لتمكن بلاده من تحديد
تاثير العقوبات وتصدير النفط واعتبر ان
الاحتجاجات التي شهدت ايران جزء من
مؤامرات العدو حسب
ما جمعيه تهديدات
من تحديد تاثير العقوبات على بلادنا
حدثت بسبب صمود شعبنا امام العقوبات صحيح
انها احد اسباب تدني العمله الوطنيه لكننا
لم تلك القدر الكافي من احتياطه نقل
الاجنبي اراد العدو الا نتمكن من تصدير
النفط لكنه وراء اننا تمكنا من ذلك اراد
ايقاف عجله الانتاج لكن الانتاج ازداد
بمقدار خمسه بالمئه ان اعمال الشغب
والعقوبات وجهان لعمله واحده